i got a box of chinese or japanese
dishes
and i had it open in my thing and that's
the only place that i think that the
snake it came out of and i know who sent
it too and it's bobby lee
wow your fat brother
[Music]
[Laughter]
so i smell dead
you smell like a
and look at this little you look like
you've been pickled or something
i could see him pulling the hair off you
and pickling your body but he's been
underground for 12 years but that i can
see that being like a new a new thing
what came out of korea getting pickled
yeah
and it makes you it makes your skin nice
and soft and wet let's not do this this
morning yeah just get into the you know
it's good yeah we're going to do it this
early we've seen that video yeah let's
get pickled
it's like a milk
bath gas jars yeah just humans in them
so you can breathe through it
and koreans do like pickles eric will
make ice cream out of his milk bath you
know
like what what anything wrong with
turning he'll make a gravy out of it
yeah you're a gravy griffin
why are you dipping biscuits in your
milk
hey i'm down [ __ ] 40 pounds
yeah
we almost looked the same size still oh
bro
he's
felt yeah
you lost 40 pounds you got a beyonce ass
over there
you really did lose weight yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's why i love seeing
bobby
dude you gotta you guys
yeah i got an idea i want to run by
bobby yeah because he's just eating a
taco bell oh eric i meant to i meant to
call you this this guy it's called from
wimp to warrior mm-hmm because we're
talking about doing something like that
so this from wimp to warrior and i was
like yeah york might be too busy because
there's some
some caveats with this so oh from wimp
to work so this guy rich chow who uh
he's the matchmaker at bellator
he's like mma royalty he's a smart smart
dude he runs
his hand in the rooka gym so what they
do is they take like a normal dude
whether comedian or not or a celebrity
not and you do a 20-week training camp
with the top coaches oh get my brother
in and you're gonna lose weight like a
[ __ ] yeah that's gonna be i
would love it it's that funny
it's at 7am
let's talk about it yeah it could be fun
content could be the content for to be
great bobby don't wake up early enough 7
a.m every day monday through friday at 7
00 a.m that's when he sleeps that's a
problem do you think you prolong that to
go to bed at 9 00 a.m
how bad you want it i don't know dude
because he was like you got anyone like
you work with her and your staff and i
was like oh my boy griffin
he's a successful successful comedian so
i don't know if he's gonna like i think
i'll get up at 7 a.m no but i think
that's the that's the fun of it it's
like you want to change your life i
think it's like inspiring to people you
know and then here's the other option
and you don't have to do this
at the end of the 20 weeks if you want
they set you up with a fight no no yeah
that's why i told him no way yes yeah no
come on if you're going to do it you
have to fight bro what if you fought
george yeah fight for your danger man
he said he wants to fight you through
theo he was a two striker
he's a two striker
it's one stripe
dude i got enough issues man almost got
him
what what you almost got into some sex
the other night you don't need a splash
of ct theo that'd be dangerous yeah it
might help me the way i'm going now yeah
you don't know where you're at sometimes
it's kind of fun um you always gotten
some sex why is that a bad thing it
wasn't bad
i just couldn't make it happen and my
body just didn't before oh your wiener
didn't wake up
you have a you have you're big down
there all right huh you're big
oh
you handle your body i'll handle my body
you're coming in
when you're gone he talks about it a lot
yeah did you have performance anxiety he
always references it like this yeah
he does that no no but he starts like
this though he goes tell me when to stop
yeah
so you couldn't get hard well look man
you have to say it out loud like that i
think
my teammates can hear you first okay
sorry about that and second of all yeah
this gal pulled up it seemed like a nice
gal
i met her when you say gal it sounds
like she's over 47. yeah
no and i should say
oh y'all in her 20s
let me think this is nashville theo this
is nashville this was in a different
city man okay you're on tour all right
in town she rolls up in a dodge charger
okay a new one and that's her man's
strength a new one two brothers in it
okay two brothers in the chat she's
white
yeah the white lady blondie oh dark
blonde sounds
yeah
keep going anyway i was like are you
gonna park and she's like nah my friends
are waiting in the car so immediately
i'm like okay yeah awkward yeah yeah
what are you talking about i felt like
it was like a game show or something
yeah like i'm not going to be able to do
this like these guys are waiting in the
car like it's cash cab yeah yeah but you
also you lost like you almost lost
respect for her you felt like what you
just told these guys hold on a second i
got to go you know have sex with theo
let me let me try to then we can go to
the club like what was that i don't know
and what were the two brothers doing the
back like what's up they look pissed at
first yeah yeah so i got him a water
they had a little valet stand right
there so i grabbed them each of water so
hey fellas here's here's a little
hydration for you yeah and then a lot of
black dudes also they ash out y'all ass
out and then what happened
what happened oh so then we tried to get
into some section she was just so angry
i was like do me
so that's why you can get a boner
yeah it just felt like it was like a um
sounds like you're having sex with nick
saban she's got like a reality
she left some of those like kind of like
up like she had some
some padding yeah those breasts like
that yeah um
don't blame yourself hey but teal this
is where you make sense what you're
saying you skipped an entire part how
did you get out of the her out of the
car with the two black guys she just
came in willy-nilly oh wow she said i'm
just kidding
these guys are fine and they stayed in
the car huh yeah probably did a podcast
or something she's stressed oh so this
is in the car i don't know if she was a
stripper or not dude because they might
be like out of the bodyguard yeah you're
gonna do me you got a rubber on you huh
you had a rubber
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he's not a delinquent man
he's not steve yeah it's not you but
you don't have four childhood wrong boys
hold on
time stamp that yeah
there's nothing more embarrassing than
putting your soft penis
yeah it reminds me like when i used to
do groceries you got to do like the
spinach or whatever you had to put it in
it try to get it in the bag and get
stuck on the edge it's a nightmare yeah
it'd still feel good though wouldn't it
no it's like trying to put toothpaste
back in the bottle no it's embarrassing
you're like hold on people you know what
it's like it's actually like you're
you're you're on a tight rope you know
what i'm saying you know and it's like
you have to really be because like that
moment you're like i'm ready to go yeah
and you know you know and especially if
you're feeling like you already have
these outside factors you're not sure if
you're really into this person sure you
know you need to get yourself out
because that moment you stop this action
all of a sudden you're like your body's
like yeah i don't really want to end
and then you're trying to uh
you know not bring attention to your
dicks you're like you're from nashville
and she's like do it yeah she's like
shut the [ __ ] up like her father was in
the military or something she might have
been in the military yeah and the female
military so she was riding you
oh no she was like kind of being naked
and uh
what
yeah is mean she looked pretty naked man
i got scared because i was like uh she
kept yelling dude
and dude i remember oh this was great
and the place i was staying in was
really nice they had like a little bit
of like a hallway so i ran and like
tried to get the blood to like and like
stop like i slid oh you're trying to oh
dude you're trying to get all the blood
in your back yeah yeah you have to do
with my body socks on oh yeah
ankle down i am i got those detroit feet
and some woman also told me i had old
feet let me check them out and that hurt
my feelings yeah you see those bad boys
because you guys do a lot of feed huh oh
yeah i've been all stationed or
something before
yeah they oh touch the part that's my
liver
thanks dude
a little ass big toe
oh you have a small big toe yeah huh
your big toe is literally the body a
little bit you know
i have a raptor qualifier
i never said that [ __ ]
bro you're a ponytail away from being
full trans right now okay you've got
like a transition ran out of money
you're gonna be a cop trans bro that's
gonna be your nickname
right now
oh here we go oh here we go i say one
thing there's a lot coming from the pog
bounty hunt hunter over here doug you
know you look identical to the [ __ ]
bounty on it he's a beautiful man yeah
he's closing in on brian landry
that's what he says he
look man this stuff look i don't do ivs
anymore i just drink liquid iv and i'll
tell you something that doesn't have
fentanyl in it yep
liquid iv guys a lot of stuff these days
you don't know what you're getting you
never know don't know the purity test of
a
gatorade you have no idea i don't trust
them one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounce
of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone what are
you doing man maybe out with your boys
all night drinking the next day liquid
iv hydrate you get done with a workout
you sweating dripping that sweet sweet
nectar out of your body replenish [ __ ]
oh it'll fill you back up it's almost
like a bee comes and just
fills your whole body with beaming
this has five essential vitamins man can
you even name five vitamins you probably
can't nope
grab your favorite liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart you can probably
find theo there as well or you can get
25 off when you go to liquidity.com use
the code cat checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you want better
hydration today use promo code cats
liquid iv.com
oh man i'll tell you something dude if
you want to uh i had a thing the other
day it was like a pork bacon
deal oh would you have a private chef
come over and cook uh it was hello
oh wow out the box baby to hit you with
the box especially if you have a family
i don't have a family
but i do have a snake that now lives in
my house and he needs to eat he needs to
eat man he's like nice hello fresh meals
dog and he wants you want that quality
meals for him yeah you want him to live
a good life man long life if you got a
family sometimes it's tough man school
is back you want to cook nice meals that
are easy they're delicious all right
hello fresh offers 50 menu and market
items choose from every single week
whatever diet you're on vegan calorie
smart special gourmet options we got
anything for everyone
yes
anything you could eat whatever your
preferences are you got it it's for
everybody for all type of sexes go to
hellofresh.com 14 king use code 14 king
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping that's hellofresh.com
free me 14 king used 14 king for up to
14 free meals fill your fridge up fill
your wife up your wife's getting big
bigger even more yeah you got it 14 free
meals fattening up your little son
uh do you see that i saw a funny [ __ ]
tweet someone said hey can we all admit
if uh dog the bounty hunter finds the
homeboy that this isn't a thing where
dog is great that our fbi just suck oh
oh laundry yeah brian
that's right yeah well how good is this
guy though yeah he's good he's high in a
different country dude he's in canada
yeah yeah oh
yeah they can get them there's only a
few countries in the world that you can
like it's not hard to be like you're
canada that's where he's saying that
he's somewhere and you don't know where
canada is
no but they're not looking for the the
cops were saying or the fbi were saying
that because of his look he has like
that bald head just normal white dude
yeah he can put on anything he looks
completely here's the thing though
bounty hunter is looking for him right
like like he's stephen no no this guy
the guy brian it can be like he can look
for him easier just like yeah let me
have you seen like a weird blonde dude
ask him for something you know yeah he
could just bounce you know he's being
the hottest six year old chick from
panama city
with that leather skirt
it just doesn't make any sense he has
that hawaiian accent even though he's
from aurora colorado yeah
he's in hawaii for two years he wants to
find he's always like aloha in
[Laughter]
already got busted dude but he didn't i
mean he just said it on the phone to a
friend yeah he did yeah
yeah yeah he fired what's this uh theo
got a gift in the mail evidently i
actually don't know the full backstory
yeah you know the back story too
were you part of this yeah stephen the
devil dancing bro what find a freaking
snake in my house a real snake yeah
who sent this [ __ ] man
okay i'm out yeah i'm like that was it
was just chilling in your house here's
what happened i got a partner there's
one thing they have a roach
caught her with a back scratcher
you look thought who sent you someone
sent that to you yeah bro you're the
lord no i didn't send that but you know
you know what's going on no you have
somebody
can i clear the air yeah please because
i know you know
i was mad at y'all
and when you went back on this on your
podcast i had to wrestle that dude and
then me and jeremiah were talking about
it and i i had like ptsd from wrestling
that guy he wasn't that was i had a
hundred pounds on him dude you
dominated him yeah but what if i thought
this through what if i didn't what if it
would have gone the other way we don't
live in the what ifs we live in
these things that's why
i was just like you know i wanted to
apologize for talking about it on
scissor bros because i know
your fans were getting on me like hey
you know how can you bite the hand that
feeds you you you backstabber and what
were people calling you that yellow n
word
what were you saying this is like the
game
you know what the game show would
yeah let me get a cheeseburger in word
black people always
so you wanted your pot because you felt
some type of way i was like paranoid of
you guys i'm like are they gonna set me
like you know what's gonna happen in
your defense jeremiah is like fox news
he's like i can't believe they would
treat you that way do you feel do you
feel tired
no issue at all i think you had a good
time man
all right i just want to get there now
i'm with you brother yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah stevie that's good yeah
we're good you know you know we love the
[ __ ] daddy i love you too
shake his hand one more time sure you
feel great
by the way beautiful let's get back to
how nasty theo's place is that snakes
just come on in yeah yeah i'll tell you
what happened i got a box of dishes
chinese dishes all right
okay oh this is like a kill bill
situation where somebody sent you a
black no they were very
you know what i'm talking about little
cups everything's a little cup yeah it's
basically a cup and y'all say it's a
plate
i got a box of chinese or japanese
dishes
and i had it open in my thing and that's
the only place that i think that the
snake it came out of and i know who sent
it too and it's bobby lee
wow your fat brother
[Laughter]
he is getting fat huh huh he's getting
real fast hey bobby do you think he sent
that snake to our friend theo over there
because he was mad at us dude first of
all my brother doesn't watch this
he knows no he doesn't watch this i sent
him uh the clip of you taking down
george you know what he told me he's
like you would never be able to do that
to me that's what he told me he's like
he can't do that to me he's like yeah
dude you couldn't do that to me well we
gotta set that that's what i said i said
come on down dude i don't watch this
so you want to see me wrestle my brother
yeah you want to see me that's my older
brother because i told you you want to
see that i do stevie i told bobby i'm
like dude i got my man stevie man it's
all his movement he still gots it has
the singlet i saw you out there that
yeah
you have to do that yeah
you know it's like a brother you're
doing the macarena right there what are
you doing
it was like i saw that thing did you see
that you didn't see the thing i saw him
checking i didn't see all that
i saw a movie
yeah you look good man you almost
fainted actually i saw at one point
who's that little diamond piece what's
going on there just a girl that was with
theo uh is that your girl
but tell your brother if he's gonna send
that [ __ ] then i'm gonna send you guys
[ __ ] too yep what are you gonna say
right oh
from [ __ ] louisiana he's just saying
you goddamn gator how do you like that
[ __ ] you want gator she said the
alligator yeah
there's a lot of love in here today so i
feel like this question's appropriate do
you want it i'm saying that'll wipe your
dick off
i'll send animal bite your dick off boy
maybe your little toe
oh there you go
you got an old feet if we get your feet
foot out here your foot [ __ ] probably
voted for uh your foot voted for home
you know churchill is not in this
country yeah it was in england
no he doesn't know
no i knew that man it's just so old
school that's super old
you know i was on your side
brendan thought they had 30 grades one
time he told me
he said oh he's not in preschool
second third fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth ninth twelfth he said he quit
after 12 grades i was like that's it bro
that's that's him
all right let's get to this diamy
hey theo brendan eric and stevie this is
eloise from anaheim and i have a debate
club for you guys
so out of the four of you which of the
two would make the best married couple
my biased opinion of course is going to
be brendan and theo but
what do you guys think let me know thank
you very gay couple me and theo would be
a fine ass girl but i got a bad [ __ ]
i'd have to grow your hair out get that
cheeks out dog get those small weird
feet in some [ __ ]
sandals it'd be lit i think the better
question is who would who would not work
i think these two this would not be good
no my butt's tight dude
and it would stay tight
okay
no they would have like love for each
other be a toxic relationship they'd be
fighting
fair enough you're sleeping in another
room you grew up dude i think me and you
would be a good couple see i think
that's probably the best yeah yeah
that's why you fight all the time but
eric's still left out i can hear all
already what are you talking about eric
would be daddy that's thick daddy over
there that's big daddy i'm running the
house yeah
i cook me five guys oh fried rice
them dishes fried rice i make you fried
rice
i just think anyone with theo is going
to be a problem
high maintenance yeah dude i got
freaking snakes in my house of course
it's tough living with me okay
you go sing out to a spouse thanks to
you guys huh you got people sending you
wild animals yeah you i saw the chinese
dishes too boys
every dish is made in china yeah i'll
kill your parents dude
dude my dad's dead
and i'm doing a good job aren't i
well that's they wanted to i don't know
sorry man i shouldn't have said that
that's okay
time stopped that i don't know who they
is this
yeah we would fight too much dude you
wouldn't be yeah you'd be making me go
to bed early
you'd be making you need to go to bed
you'd be reading me the newspaper and
[ __ ] in the morning i ain't doing all of
that i got to get them i picked you guys
you guys
in the morning [ __ ] powder on your back
and legs i ain't doing all of that [ __ ]
man would you eat his nuts
okay steve
yeah we're talking about being life
partners it's just like are you going to
eat his brothers
he
no no you two would be the best couple
because all you all talk about is sex
all the time
you look like chris cyborg if she
[ __ ] that the swelling went down a
little
and you
you know what you're doing baby boy you
would hide him probably in his buttocks
yeah
he's live there well from the back asian
is good you know what i'm saying you
won't even know
good back rubs yeah there you go
massages
i think of cb looks like the karaoke
he's down to bring in somebody else i
fear you're open-minded oh no i'd poison
him oh let me poison me with rice and
i've been in the one town baby yeah tim
what do you think over here you see
these beautiful men in here who would
make the best relationships i think nick
and chen would make a great relationship
no way no way and i think meatballs
would be some bad little short kings
look we don't need another they what if
they make another short person yeah we
we don't need more short people
well well that's not gonna happen yeah
that's not yeah that's not the cards for
you
what are you talking about yeah ask
daddy over here
what do you get you guys are gonna it's
gonna be even shorter
that blood is going to get even more
diluted
we wouldn't be just that's offended
there's just no attraction
there's nothing i feel like you're
really quiet this is a hypothetical i'm
not just saying we're making a
hypothetical right look at bodies
compatible relationships i don't like
tall i don't like tall in the first
place so it's got to be smaller oh you
know
i don't i don't like me and chin oh you
don't want to be a mask
[Laughter]
nick who do you think could make the
best couple i think eric and stevie just
similar interests i mean they already
talked like one's going to
keep us getting cooking clean they'll
play video games yeah yeah they got a
lot in common but what about the sex i
run a tight house
stevie a little that's like
oh
got that herpes on him that's what he's
got dude you know what i'm talking about
that's what he's worried about i'm sorry
well damn i feel like we all just fell
out of a big relationship
yeah i know yeah
i feel like we're not close anymore for
some reason we've decided that we can't
live together you're too dirty
90 of the dudes out there have
flashlights like me
yeah i mean right guys
but they don't name it help me out i'll
sing gator for you help me out there's
eight people in here and you're the only
one
hey kyle help me out a little bit
help me
all
out
all right what's this dude guys dude
this is terrence ross isn't it yeah yeah
that's the end of me he's a baller this
is the homie
he's just he's a fan of podcasts and
stuff like that he has a podcast
what's up fellas it's your boy t ross um
i got a debate topic question for you
guys
um the biggest thing streaming right now
is squid games and um i'm kind of
curious out of u4
who do you guys think would win or
complete the square games let me know i
kind of personally think it's going to
be brendan because it all matters when
you get down the line to that squid game
and it gets a little more physical i
just don't see
you know
white women
i think he just celebrated 10 years with
his wife yeah dude he's married
to cut that out
it's like a korean drama series but it's
like hunger games it's it's really good
it's like
it's really good give me an example of
people people that are down on their
luck
they get uh convinced to they sign up
for these games
yeah dude arizona or turkey oh that's
florida you have some mitts on them yeah
bro what planet is that on brenda
good for him
she's bad yeah
so so the people are like so like
they're all down on their legs
but they don't realize that this is a
like a game for your life so the first
game is red light green light and they
make the instructions come on you know
red light green line you have to stop or
you will be eliminated so you think
eliminating means you have to leave the
field no they just everybody's getting
shot dude oh damn yeah and then so then
you realize that the games are all
lethal after that i'm good and there's
six six games that happened oh that's
dope yeah okay
okay
[Laughter]
pulled outside a little time
and then when it turns around it has
these um cameras in its eyeballs and
you've never done styles
there's guns shooting the the so it just
becomes like it's like it's like a real
have a little
while
sit down
there you go
there you go little boo i had some i
have something no no no
why does he need two smoothies who are
you yeah we have two smoothies
y'all ain't gotta worry about my
smoothie bro
if y'all watch movies guess movies y'all
got zero's movies we missed those i
didn't know yeah
we were how about when how come we
weren't asked
the game yeah
but anyway it's a really good series on
netflix yeah everyone yeah you should
definitely watch a good one we're not
even allowed to play it's only is it for
who's it for what are you talking about
the movie you guys have seen
the korean drama everyone can watch it
though
let me ask you this though this is a
question
um i watched it like with the english
dub over cause i can't stand reading
movies but it kills it kind of though
it does yeah it doesn't kill it but it's
not as good it's nice
though the first the first few episodes
and this is just a style of like that
korean style yeah very over the top yeah
but the comedy is very like but then it
really like less it really gets serious
i'm gonna wait till they remake and put
matt damon as the lead character i
should do it well you will be waiting a
long time first of all for that what do
you mean a remake of uh you roll for
that i'm waiting for matt damon
it's not all koreans either there's like
uh other people there's a pakistani yeah
which i love i love that guy is there
anything
though and a couple probably later maybe
they weren't standing yeah it's so good
yeah it's a mindset
it's like i believe people
yeah
you know i will dude nobody needs help
and uses more help than i do dude yeah
you're right man but you need better
help dude and whatever help you're using
i think you should get better
and that's where our friends at better
help come in man they have brendan
something's interfering with your
happiness prevent you from achieving
your goals or being mean to your co-host
go to better health that's it they will
assess your needs and match you with
your own license professional service
man we should start communicating
this whole show to an episode man yeah
sit down with a therapist and talk it
out we should i wonder if that'd be
great yeah
you think we'll both start crying real
we'd make real progress real
breakthrough that's a great oh yeah i
bet my tears though wouldn't test
positive for uh peds yeah mine would
that's one thing i do but they don't
judge that's when you talk to a real
licensed professional with better help
start living a happier life today man it
doesn't matter if you're on steroids not
on steroids if you drink coffee jacking
off not jacking off no judgment man
these are real
counselors help betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
uh this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and king and the sting
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com kets now what did you
guys ever have to play games for food at
your house when you're growing up and
here we are and we're back everybody
huh
like you didn't play rake rock paper
scissors for dinner or some [ __ ] no
no no or you die yeah none of that
we grew up normal
well next uh
he's you're naked and he's naked keep
going back to sleep
um
it was one time there was two brothers
waiting in a charger she didn't cut that
engine off that's a lot of pressure i'm
with you okay this is your kid's fault
oh wow that's what did she expect from
you she thought you were like a two
minute hitting quiddit she's like just
keep the car running theo ain't gonna be
able to last that long she thought you
were chris brown or some [ __ ] i mean
jesus christ man oh that she was yelling
at you she was yeah but if she's bad
enough all right
all right does she smell nice yell at me
did she smell good she seemed like a
really nice girl i don't have anything
bad to say about her she just
was very i think women nowadays are just
very adamant about what they want
at least she's up front you know no
blurred lines she's pretty though pretty
late she didn't open she didn't tell you
hey i'm swinging by for a couple minutes
and i got my brothers in the car and uh
can i can we just go here you thought it
was gonna be like a bit more romantic
didn't you i may have i mean i may have
thought it was going to be a bit more
romantic i did turn on the television
um did you have candles lit was there
music playing did you put out the good
sheets were there snakes on the ground
yeah how did you have the place set up
so you probably disappointed
no i remember i put on the tv i put it
on hulu i couldn't remember my login i
said [ __ ] it and just left it on
and
then i waited for her to come up i i i
opened the door a little bit so she
wouldn't so because i felt like
sometimes closed doors seemed scary to
people so i open the door no not at all
the door's even scary open doors like
what is she going to walk into you're
going to be like a circus outfit
like come on in you know what though
kind of underwear was she wearing huh
what kind of undies would you wear i
think adult underwear i think
for the most part adult underwear stevie
all about this yeah
stevie sackey
stevie's bad guy you need to talk
something
betterhelp.com promo code stevie's bad
guys family sent snake master yeah
so this is gonna be in your spank bank
uh steve
well maybe maybe not theo would just
just socks on and yeah a very aggressive
woman
she's gotta hit him i wanna see the
weight down the hallway trying to get
that blood i want to see what you're
working with huh i bet you there's some
beautiful woman in your dms oh yeah huh
bailey tipped me up
me too always what a beautiful man
little butterfly who's this i don't know
who that she knows about you okay
whatever she knows about you she loves
you your family
to my house she loves you huh little
butterfly yeah
you know what it is because you're like
eve and they sent you the snake to tempt
you oh yeah oh i like that yeah i'm
gonna grill this gentleman what nick
is our last debate club beautiful guy
right here boys theo bishop stevie weeby
eric whoever the [ __ ] in there this
week
trust me trust me that's how we feel
jessame was nicely shot you finally got
a lady in here yeah
great chica
yeah oh that's a lady that's a looker
did you feel any spice between you
already well
they shot it down real quick i noticed
that but didn't you feel anything you
did you're like you don't stand a chance
i'm sorry no it's okay
steve kept talking about his dick size
how big you want my dick to be just tell
me when this guy is like here
tell me when to stop telling you oh you
better stop soon you better stop saying
that's your brother no that's my problem
you're obsessed with sex yeah you came
out the gate too hot you think so yeah
yeah you're talking about your dick size
before you knew her did i really do that
yeah
that's why i was like stevens you're out
of ten i knew you had a four yeah and i
think you got to do more like but she
wanted a 10 and steve's at a four
that's what i'm saying
see how easy it was from to stand up
like there's no weight even between his
legs
you'll be fine stevie a lot of it is
gross
dude there's got to be do i need
betterhelp.com because that's my sponsor
for mine this weekend have brandon kick
you in the pituitary gland i think you
probably know the real type of
friend of friends help me out he might
make it go to betterhelp.com
totally different sites yeah oh yeah
dude he just bought he's probably buying
automobiles from like a sex website
i do what i do on my own time
oh there's two
right here debate club
what is he doing
what should he be more ashamed of going
over four
or stick in those hands where they don't
really belong
let me know gang gang buzz buzz nick you
have the video of him getting uh grinded
on by that young chick now is he at the
bar just chilling she comes and starts
rubbing her ass on him i didn't i
haven't seen any beginning this is uh
one of the videos this is just where it
ends
give me context what is this this is uh
the jacksonville jaguars head coach
famous college football oh and this is
one of the most famous most successful
calls for walk coach all the time
finally went to the nfl's with the
jackson jaguar what's going on
do they know it's him yeah that's him
and he's chilling at a club
the night after he went lost his fourth
game well he grabs his girl's booty i
don't think he did that
uh he's trying to put his finger yeah
what's he do
really well she's doing something she
put someone really got a video of urban
meyer trying to stick his fingers up my
ass but she was standing there and
grinding on him and stuff i think more
people are just upset because a he's
married and b
and b he shouldn't be celebrating after
being over four it's not that he was
like assaulting her
okay so he needs to leave that thing go
to usc
you're telling me hand me the glasses in
the hat so i could do an impersonation
these are the glasses you're gonna be
wearing about a year because you need
them
so you're telling me we're like the same
age this [ __ ] he was he
was two and two
it's okay if he grabs this girl's ass if
you're four and oh two and two you can't
i'm with him on this i knew he would no
no no cause he's the thing here's a
twofold problem
this is out of context if they're not
showing the part where she's like you
know if they're having a flirting
situation yeah i'm fine with that okay
two he's married so
if you have a problem with that then you
have a problem with that but that's
separate from trying to make him out to
be a pervert he's just engaging in
whatever is happening here okay three
peyton manning his first when he was a
rookie he was one in 15
and he had just as terrible as stats as
this rookie quarterback trevor lawrence
okay it's a rookie quarterback he
shouldn't be starting but he's the
number one pick so they have to put him
in there it takes time it takes time
yeah so next year if he gets his groin
pains out if they suck again next year
then then urban mind's gonna be fired
but this is just like the growing pains
of what's going on so it's just i'm
trying to pile on this is what i'm
saying this is layered this is a layered
issue my bigger question is what [ __ ]
bar are they at in jacksonville where
it's this lit you ever been to
jacksonville i've never been to florida
jacksonville is like basically it's you
ever seen one of those trailer fights
yes that's jackson where it's half half
full that's jacksonville this was uh the
wife or the tweet from his wife the
night he went out so like people were
thinking they probably have some type of
understanding
uh well those those are the his grand
kids
his kids are growing and his daughter is
a dime piece there was another one where
like dad's out he he deserves it or
something like that
well they're just trying to downplay it
they're trying to make it like you know
he also you know he makes 10 million
dollars a year they're not trying to
right
they're saying they're trying to be on
the street how much would you have to
make
to have let your wife be out having
another family you think have another
life family another life going on and
she's like taking care of you
how much would she have to make your
wife to let you think if you have a wife
i see what you're saying well you have a
wife you you have a wife too almost
basically the real question would be
that's right dude be nice but you don't
ever plan on having a wife do you uh
no
i'm too weird i'm too i'm too weird club
you got that herpes baby you better
tighten up son
this guy's got a clown my hound for us
we haven't done that in a while wait
what happened to the other guy what
happened to t ross uh
did we did we need to get
games yeah he's good yeah brandon
wouldn't win check out t ross pockets
we didn't really discuss that we didn't
discuss it no but there's somewhere it's
not physical it's like the marble
remember the marvel thing theo would win
because he's more conniving yeah is that
it's like big brother yeah you have to
use your brains too the i don't know
he's like the guy that got the frank
killed in the show
no no no no no no yeah he's the he's
he's the only one
the deceiver yeah yeah he's the deceiver
yeah yeah i haven't seen so people
there's one challenge where it has to be
but what about this though what i'm
trying to say is uh who would win squid
game baby i think either
why don't you you don't think you'd win
i don't know you'd slip in your own
semen at the starting line i bet you
died
i definitely wouldn't win unless the
competition is who can like you know
who's the old guy in it though billy
crystal you see billy crystal's
is he rich yeah yeah
pretty crazy man
i don't know who would win
yeah but if it came down to physical
fighting obviously yeah it ain't coming
at an effect dude it does in the end it
does oh it does
don't ruin it well that's the end
it's street it's on everybody's watched
it sorry spoiler alert get your [ __ ]
everybody me see this little bad [ __ ]
nick stevie wonder ass over here
from north carolina sure it is t ross
undercover over here we know who it is
saw this little bad boy on the streets i
think he got on carolina got a little
clown my hound what's not my hound
saw this little bad boy roaming the
streets i think he got on a boat from
trinidad
might have been nicki's cousin i don't
even know [ __ ] it might be spider-man
he's definitely shooting some rope
uh let me know what you guys think gang
gang bust nuts
damn what's going on boy he got some
noises
yeah you got to milk him though yeah
yeah
you need that operation balls man yeah
referencing nicki minaj's cousin who got
giant testicles from supposedly the
vaccine came out so that was a lie oh
really yeah it came out said that that's
not real yeah she's yeah she's getting
eaten alive yeah that's not right she
should yes
pandemic you know what i mean yeah you
need an operation
yeah it's not either as a tumor or the
biggest blue ball yeah
you got to cut that out that's cancer
yeah you don't know that's answer bro
that could be god also trying to send a
message man what's the message yeah we
need to hear what this message is go
ahead yeah
the message could be anything man like
a message
well tell us what your message is
you see those messages from there and
what message are you hearing
life's short question let me think about
it for a second see if i can channel
some of it
you channeling now
i would just say that this dude get one
snake now he [ __ ] missed cleo
he missed cleo all of a sudden he got
one snake somebody sent me a dm and said
that snake is probably a messenger
trying to sell you something
it could be and i know what it is too
big nuts no that your family is [ __ ] boy
that's what that snake came all the way
and told me huh you sent me a bunch of
30 dishes in the no that's bob in a
freaking chinese japanese newspaper
well now you have to like i'd be scared
to get anything else in there that's how
i feel
is that snake poisoning it's a rat snake
is it poisonous no wrestling you think
i'll wear this shirt around it though
[ __ ] no i can't that's why i wore this
shirt out here in california i can't
wear this shirt in my house
you just gonna wake up the snake it's
gonna be on your chest
give me your big rat but i think if i
saw those big nuts man i would say maybe
it's time to start a family would be the
message i would get from the other side
that's fair
and things are full it's time to hold
back man my new thing i've been doing
anyway is edge lordin what's that what's
that it's when you don't uh do
ejaculation
you look like that too
why would you do that there huh
why would you she hadn't talked about
this already
for like a month you get more focused
like two months chen's hair is doing it
so why don't we
your testosterone when you do that
nothing's for children it's supposed to
hire it no it lowers it because your
body goes oh we don't need to do this
and use it so it shuts it down i don't
know but i stopped doing it so it's all
good because boxers used to do that
ejaculate no fighters used to do that
and then literally there's research for
two months though it lowers your time is
it helping you know
that's the new show great man i feel i
don't know how long you've been doing it
uh probably almost five days
ever since well it sounds like you
didn't ever want to show the two black
guys yeah something you didn't want to
do something's not an option
and threw some wendy's out the passenger
side looks like a window
i said damn bro
again
how can i get you wrecked during this
type of stuff they came to your place
and i didn't know where you live
uh this is a hotel so read the
definition i can't read my eyes
yeah what's the definition say though
there's edging and there's edge lord so
what's that
is it oh edgelord is the thing that i've
been into man that's what i am what's
the difference i don't know if it has a
definition or not someone posted on the
internet who uses shocking
speech opinions that they themselves may
or may not actually believe to gain
attention oh there's a bunch of little
[ __ ] oh yeah
is the practice of engaging in sexual
stimulation to the point of ejaculation
before stopping and starting again but
eventually you have to do it though you
have to let god pull it out of you at
night while you sleep so you have to nut
no this is like it's supposed to
eventually maybe not because it helps
the orgasm yeah yeah supposed to make
the orgasm even more intense damn why
give you all this regular sex what's
wrong with y'all i notice my hearing's
even better
to god dude five days my hearing's
better and it's easy for me to move my
fingers if i'm reading like uh trying to
get through a book or something i feel
like your hair's growing faster so you
read like this like your hair is long
bro is it like you sent me those
pictures from the special here's long oh
thanks man
patrick swayze a little bit dog yeah how
do you make this just he's been dead you
can do that while you masturbate and
don't nut
no you don't i don't even mess with you
you don't want to start that master bed
no
you don't no you can't i'm done man
you're done doing it
[Applause]
now penis is done we're done man it's
like coach k retiring wow that's like it
was a good run though huh that's like a
jedi thing it was a it was a good run
and it was a bad run man we had some
odds we had some lows oh yeah yeah
those valleys are low you're not
masturbating anymore are you
on the road maybe occasionally
you get lonely daddy out there busting
up because i'll face time with my little
hotel room in your hotel room with the
motion
you jack off to your
good for you man
good for you what are you talking about
i'm sorry that i'm still attracted to
the one i love
i am
i love vanilla ice cream but sometimes
if i'm jacking off i like to see what
strawberry looks like you feel like i
like that yeah
what he's saying is you like the window
shop yeah then you go home and spend the
money
i like to eat get here yeah friend we're
here theo you can now you see people
wondering why why we set the positions
where we are this is why we say where we
are
this is the people that are still
struggling together
oh because you guys have your [ __ ]
together yeah yeah get your glasses on
you put those glasses on what are you
saying
look at this sin over here huh there is
santa i like to look
if you look at his phone there's a lot
of x's on there
in the photo section i did uh
i did look at a uh i did have a bite of
cookie the other day and i said ah
too much yeah i just just said you ain't
doing you ain't tricking me no more damn
you gave up cookies and
sugar i gave up give me two thirds of a
cookie your life sounds awful wow
what are you doing tell me i got snakes
coming through my life you're making
life changes huh life changes yeah maybe
i am actually
good for you maybe you're growing up
this guy's looking for some relationship
advice
last night i saw hink williams jr live
uh i enjoyed it a lot i got my needles
on
theo i see you with it on that's what's
up
looking fresh rat king but anyway
uh so pretty much i'm asking for some
relationship advice bruh
um
with my first girlfriend
and
i was trying to get back with her and
she was giving no effort
and pretty much the tables have turned
as that as i would describe it and now
she's trying to text me and i'm like
i want nothing to do with you like
straight up but i haven't replied or
anything so
any tips
any life advice
for a pretty [ __ ]
love you guys
you guys help me is this andre the giant
son you know what i mean
look this andre the giant sentence is
the longest
i'm good and now she's blown him up and
he's like i'm good dude it sounds like
an ego thing yeah
it's like getting over your pride if
you're indoors what are you doing if
you're into her get in there she came
back around we need brian laundry to
send in a question
yeah from canada
theo so when you're trying to get away
that'd be amazing
bro brian laundry if you're out there
man if you're still alive dude send us
in or something if you need relationship
advice
if you need
i think we're past the relationship
advice
i think he
yeah
that's what i'm saying dude this guy's
got a way more interesting so this guy
looks like mike
is one of the star brothers
the third star brother yeah dude
what's up brendan what's up ceo and
whoever the [ __ ] showed up um
wait first of all i take offense to this
just stop it right there yeah stop it
right there cause i think you know
something yeah no no no no no no don't
say that because we show up here
[Applause]
get that [ __ ] out of here we want field
bread yeah
we want a white butt
we want a white book
i'm in burnsville minnesota
i don't want to be here either sure you
are bro travel forward so
my question is um my girlfriend's
pregnant
and i'm gone for a long time like a
month to six weeks at a time i'm only
back for a little bit so uh
brendan like get up eternity
spicy what you do like
make something like that work because i
know you're on the road theo you'll
never have a family so i'm not gonna
care about your opinion oh shoot if
anybody else has got something for me
let me know appreciate you guys
look there's been a lot of stuff that's
going on this episode mike brown could
have put on some what if my ground
retired put on some weight try drinking
beer i don't know you can't tell what
that guy's built like it's not mike
brown no
they both have beards
mike brown would be nicer to you yeah
like i've gone for a month though
how often though bro how long are you
allowed to leave the house eric these
days
yes a lot
like i'm going to a destination wedding
with her this week oh you bringing
where's the destination it was cabo oh
damn damn yeah oh nice yeah balling yeah
he's making some dough now these
blankies out here with that cash huh new
condo
i don't know i didn't repeat it
but i do have a lot of out-of-town gigs
i've been going out of town you know
thursdays to sunday yes you know for a
lot so it is what it is you just got to
find ways to spend time when you get
back yeah when you're there you have to
count yeah will you do something like
the night you get back do you have to go
out that night and go to dinner are you
allowed to kind of wait a night yeah we
do we do date night once a week oh so
like tonight we have date night because
i'm on the road thursday there you go
what are you doing then i'll pick up the
kids uh pick them up and drop them off
from school when i'm here every day so
it's dinner and a movie like dinner just
dinner okay we got like a really nice
dinner you guys don't arm wrestle
oh hell no that'd be funny his girl was
a ring girl dude no she wasn't
mexican wasn't she she was one of those
well she was she was miss mexico but she
was missing she was missing she was miss
mexico yeah and do not start googling
you free
yeah yeah don't use that in your spank
bank tonight no no i wouldn't know dude
i would never disrespect yes
i promise yes
pinky promise i respect that i won't do
that thanks doug but but will you ever
look up your wife
ever what about my wife huh this guy
dear's gonna get some battery he's gonna
fall in love guaranteed i feel like i'm
probably gonna get somebody pregnant at
some point 100 percent dude i remember i
got uh give me a step dad you look like
a step dad chromidia one time yeah and
this is probably
a week or two ago
no but i got it cured and then went back
and got it again from the same girl she
was that
you went back did you even confront her
about it are you no she wasn't trying to
act
because you're like man it's only some
antibiotics dude i had a roommate at the
time this dude
calvin right and he had these kiwi get
high and he had these cats that he would
train them in the living room to do
different type of stunts and jump in
boxes yeah weird and we had high living
room ceilings right
so he'd get those sometimes i come home
he'd have four seven eight empty boxes
all stacked up just catting
you know these [ __ ] all up in there
you know 18 feet up in the sky and he's
just doped out ninja warriors fired up
yeah before ninja warrior yeah
so anyway
um
uh i was moving out some girl came and
looked at the room right and she was
cute bruh she was
well i believe it she's a little jerk
and uh and then what happened was i
ended up taking her out that night and
then she gave me chlamydia
yeah what did the cat stuff have to do
with yeah why are you busting this chick
raw
i just want
yeah i saw him break his silverware out
too when i mentioned it
over here first of all
so the cats distracted you were like i
don't need a condom because of these
cats oh but then we snuck back in real
quiet into the apartment because the guy
was looking to rent the room to the he's
like i gotta find a roommate man
and you had left so you're like we gotta
sneak back in here for a little more
chlamydia
and then i got it cured thank god that's
an easy one and then i got it again from
her she must be because i wasn't sure if
she said i didn't give it to you and i
said i think you did yeah so then i
guess we kind of proved it
[Laughter]
you needed that empirical there's only
one way to find out yeah
all right we'll close out with a couple
kingdoms yeah
little blue eyes
yeah
jesus christ
you just told the story how you got cat
media right now yeah okay yeah
i like you man
you're the same one
huh hi theo hi brendan hi stevie hi eric
wherever the [ __ ] else is there today
hi brandon steve eric
messing up our show that we love
hey you guys
[ __ ] off
okay
all right yeah [ __ ] you where's the
thanks for keeping the show exist yeah
we're breaking our backs over here man
you think i like driving to calabasas
every frickin
tuesday they have to deal with this
[ __ ] i know they don't even get yeah
they ain't got a full kitchen in this
[ __ ] it's the respect that we get you
can't even
but the man who attempted to assassinate
ronald reagan in like 1981 legends
released johnny
so king enters it being granted
unconditional release after attempting
to assassinate the president be with it
or no unconditional release that's
obviously
a question for you loves young blue eyes
i just farted sorry
oh did you smell it huh you smell it
yeah why do you think i turned that over
to you okay that's an unconditional
release 81 i mean he the guy served his
time i mean ronald reagan that was in
the 80s yeah correct that's right so
it's been all right [ __ ] [ __ ]
fortunate
yeah but you don't
prison's supposed to rehabilitate people
so if that's what's up
then why did why not just kill him then
i think he got sentenced to life but
then they let him out here's what i
don't know but life isn't life life is
25 years yeah 25 so they so they got
like so he must have got like four yeah
four life sentences or whatever it was
here's my thing like you know the they
got to make that life sorry you know
squeaky from she was the one who stabbed
sharon tate
yeah she was andre ryan's girlfriend
correct with those you're talking about
left eye different different but both
evil one could dance and sing though um
but squeaky from she was 16 when she
committed that murder she was so high on
drugs she was like on [ __ ] heroin and
acid yeah and then she was basically
conned into it through uh tex they got
they killed it they killed sharon tate
but she's 16 and she's in california
prison and every like 10 years she's up
for parole and she's like a model
assistant now she like does all her shut
her
uh it might not be squeaky from there's
one still in prison who did the murders
she was honest
she was 16 when she did it she was on
ask she was acid and she was like kind
of forced to do it but that every year
newsome was is like absolutely not like
bro since 16. come on that was in that
was it 68 1968. look but he got to make
all these children get vaccinated you
heard what he's doing yeah a piece of
[ __ ] he's going to make all these you
got a [ __ ] six-year-old in a damn
wheelchair or something
and he going to make him get damn
[ __ ] inked out or whatever no he's
the worst
well but you're not going to get
vaccinated now because no not happening
but how do you get around it i moved to
texas
oh you're moving no i'm not moving trust
here's the thing that's going to be
y'all to
[Laughter]
what's this bad
this guy's hilarious
he's diversified a little bit let's
brown out a little round it up take 19
action what up king and the sting this
is aj
wisconsin i got a king of the stinger
for you going on vacation by yourself
i'm headed out to dallas this week i'm
going to catch me a cowboy game
i'ma wander around the city for a couple
days with no one to get in my way and
friday i'm gonna go heckle montez since
the website made me buy two tickets and
it's just me i might as well bring my
[ __ ] baby
yeah let me know what you guys think
king king it king it looks like you're
riding around smoking cigarettes with
the windows up buddy let's take a break
from that and go help brendan with the
mad reads because they're kicking his
ass
there is a lot of comments about young
gang
king at king it that's that's i think
that's the second most comment it's
about like what's up with brandon and
these ad reads
people hate ads in general well here's
the thing ad reads i gotta do them all
on fire kid all in here by the time you
guys see me i've done my 17th adventure
i got you yeah my friend patrick i went
to school what they got on the left oh
really oh they showed up to the show
it was fun times when when were you in
dallas this past weekend how was it it
was great you like texas man um it was
five dollars man and this past week and
this past weekend yeah i'm in dallas
november 11th 13th that's where westeros
almost got shot who drama jfk he did get
shot got shot you guys didn't kinky or
sting that one yeah vacation by yourself
vacation by yourself it's fine
[Music]
i mean you know what you know i feel
that way it's because i travel by myself
all the time anyway so i go to
restaurants by myself i go to movies by
myself when i'm on the road so i used to
be like before i'd be like oh this is
uncomfortable now i i love it i love
doing the movies by myself so i don't
got to deal with nobody it's just me
enjoying it exact opposite i travel with
five dudes at all times i hate being
alone i don't like hotel rooms by myself
you don't like being alone who hurt you
i always have people around you
not me
i love being alone alone alone really
then why every story you have you got
somebody submissive and getting ejacked
on yep no get massages in the
philippines for seven bucks that
happened once yeah why can't you make it
through one day without having semen you
know what i won't beat off tonight there
you go bubba ooh it's a star that's a
challenge i don't believe it you know
what i'm facetiming i'll make sure you
don't
you will no that's gonna help him what
are you talking about
should we do one more last one yeah
oh wow oh oh it's like if me and theo
had a baby this brian little [ __ ]
if you and me had a baby yeah
let's take few of you as a history
teacher yeah
this is theo with a jerry curl yeah
that would be nice to him
that's hilarious what's up king in the
sting this is steaming coming from
that watching trail of maine
just made it to the 2 000 mile mark you
can see right here
i got a king here stinging for you
appalachian trail that long distance
through hiking about getting down and
dirty in nature are you
more one of the indoor cats let me know
gang gang buzz buzz
i'm [ __ ] ready king it i want
him as my tour guide king it dawg i took
seo on a hike one time he was slipping
all over man he wore soccer shorts and
some [ __ ] sketchers
he was slipping all over the mud
complaining the whole time because you
lied to me i love camping told me he was
going to wish him well you know
we get over there there's no wishing no
well it's just uphill mudslide lava
lava
the place he took me very much rich
people it's where they take poor people
to see lava this theo look at this this
is it
look at him laughing and he had cleats
on this deep who
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
white
[Laughter]
you still got them there dog i cleaned
them up for you you're welcome to keep
them i like that i like that yeah i
appreciate you cleaning them for me
actually is that it nick that's it yeah
fun show man glad you're back mr theovan
happy to be back man good to see you
guys holding the show yeah i'm excited
for your special bro i'll be back next
week
special
um it's coming out october 19th ooh i
can't wait for you man it's gonna be a
big deal holy [ __ ] we'll be coming out
check it out on netflix yeah october
19th i think yes it's gonna be great man
yeah i'm in uh vegas this weekend new
club wise guys it's downtown vegas for
the locals it is this thursday friday
saturday the next week i'm in brea brea
improv is friday and saturday only
friday and saturday next week brea
and then the big one dallas addison
improv november 11th through the 13th
it's gonna be a special night i'll give
you more details as we get closer well
i'm going to a wedding this week but
next weekend i'm at comedy on state in
wisconsin all right so come check me out
there and then the week after that i'm
in the arlington draft house oh that one
yeah and me and jeremiah are doing
another comedy festival um is he gonna
go battle over a comedy festival
st louis missouri
november 13th
and jeremiah's gonna be like so steve
why do they hate you go
everybody go support stevie
meanwhile you know we love jeremiah deal
you got more road dates another this
unborn barbecued child got mailed here
earlier today yeah
scissor bros
uh i got some uh shows knoxville 10 oh
that was this weekend actually baltimore
maryland the black maine they call it
weird and then i'm out in uh i feel
about performing in some place called
black
okay
can you change to the maine
[Laughter]
i got wilkes bar minneapolis charleston
burlington vermont baltimore
coming up theovan.com tour deals like
come watch me at the n-word maine
all right love you guys love you guys
brendan and theo fighter and wait i
gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino burning ain't the queso
and the quesoritos but everything's
gonna be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you driving couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo diaz you
don't want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible brandon's son hit me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up
oh yeah king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you